good morning ah they do work are we
online Brad all right thank you good
morning everybody it's good to see you
all this is going to be a pretty
uh what's the word I'm looking for easy
day it's good to see you all back you
must just missed this place uh before we
get started can we rise for the pledge
please
thank you for that uh so the today's
executive session is going to deal with
the
the nine bills that we move to put into
interim study uh the only motions that
we'll be entertaining today on each one
of these bills is do we recommend for
future legislation or do we not
um I did put the onus on the prime
sponsor of this bill when we decided to
go interim study
and just as a footnote and I decide
we're going to believe we'll take them
up in order this is completely
unrehearsed and so we do have a quorum
and I guess we'll get going uh I'll open
up the executive session on interim
representative tolerski
thank you Mr chair I'm not totally sure
what the exact wording is but I move not
recommended for future legislation
if
you can remind me of the actual terms
okay yeah hold on one second
amen is there a second
I'll second
okay uh I saw representative Fox first
would you care to speak to your motion
sure
um 522 speaks to
um
extending the requirement for
inspections to a longer period of time
for newer vehicles or vehicles that are
still under warranty now what we came
out of the public hearing with is that
there were lots of undefined terms
we had lots of testimony on the variable
use that can cars can have in that time
period from you know leaving the lot to
two years in you could put five thousand
miles on a car you can put a hundred
thousand miles on a car a lot of vehicle
inspections they look at those items
that wear out and use such as brakes
tires wipers that kind of thing and I
think we uh
heard convincing testimony that there's
just too much
open-ended questions
and that a one size fits all changed to
the vehicle inspection law just doesn't
thank you for that anybody else from the
committee
seeing none
I'll just say this I'm looking at the
the text of this actual bill as I said
before I did put the onus on the prime
sponsors I have not heard a word
um and he was well aware of the issues
that were raised when we heard this
um I'm not necessarily opposed to making
a change for the first two years but I
don't know if we'll be ready for that I
started looking at some initial
information and trying to separate the
failure rate for for vehicles one in two
years old but it's going to re require
some more in-depth looking at so
I at this point have no issue uh with
the motion to
not recommend
anybody else
okay just so you know too this is the
recommendation based on the language of
this bill it does not by any means tie
the hands of any legislator that wants
to go across the street to OLS and file
something anyway this is basically a
formality for the bills that we had left
over from this past year
that being said I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll the motion on the floor is
to not recommend further legislation
hey representative gagne
yes
a clerk votes yes
I spend down my list uh representative
Rambo
yes
representative rich
representative tolerski yes
representative Fox yes
representative Ayo yes and chairman
Walsh
foreign
1901 nine to one
that's just a look it will not be here
there will be not another minority
reports so so right now the
recommendation at this point and again
narrowly looking at the context of this
bill is to not recommend future
legislation so even if you think it's a
good idea to move to a two-year
exemption
I'm looking more specifically at this
language I don't think it works it could
be another way to do it
so I have a question I have a question
Mr chairman
yeah go ahead
um you just characterized what the vote
was for on that specific Bill about that
specific language in the bill
but but really I think what we're saying
is
um
my my Noble is that it is worthy of
future legislation not not that that
piece of legislation is the correct
piece of legislation is that not right
again it's open for interpretation I
agree with you
um as and again like I said at the
beginning concept wise
I am not uh opposed to looking at a
two-year exemption on brand new vehicles
either
but
with not having any support at the
beginning of this debate I figured I
would
just to move things along go ahead with
non-recommendation or and and
again no hands are tied from this as we
learn more things in the future
uh give me a moment next bill we'll look
okay I'll open up the executive session
on interim study build house bill 628
relative to maximum vehicle speed
limitations
uh Prime sponsors representative Yokel I
have not heard a thing from him
um this one actually blanketly raises
all speed limits in the state of New
Hampshire by I believe five miles an
hour on all types of most types of Roads
representative Hill uh thank you Mr
chairman I would move
um
not to recommend future legislation okay
so the Motions to not recommend future
legislation is that seconded is that
going to buy representative tolerski
anything to say
I recommend not
anybody else from the committee
yeah we um we looked at this at the
beginning
um
it's just too wide a scope to just
randomly raise everything
and then these days driving on a regular
basis knowing that if I do the speed
limit right now I'm actually a hazard I
don't know if this is the time to be
raising speed limits anywhere quite
honestly once again it does not stop
anybody from filing a bill if they can
find specific roadways that are
justifiable to raise
with nobody else I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll the motion is to not
recommend future legislation uh Vice
chairman gagne
yes
clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Gorski yes
representative tolerski yes
representative rich
I'm going up the bank representative
Rambo yes
representative Fox yes representative
yes
okay so the committee vote is 10-0 to
not recommend future legislation
and representative Hill has just turned
himself a committee report thank you sir
give us a couple of minutes and we'll
regroup we are going in order for what's
okay I'll open up the executive session
on interim study bill House Bill 1445 FN
relative to identification of police
vehicles
the prime sponsor is representative
trottier
I have heard nothing
in in addressing any of the concerns
that we had
I'll make that motion
with help afterwards and what motion is
that emotion is not recommended for
future legislation okay so the motion is
not recommend for future legislation is
there a second
second by representative tolerski did
you wish to comment if
I don't have the bill before me because
I the dog ate my homework apparently
uh but I if I my memory serves me these
are the unmarked state police vehicles
who are
um
if you've got any kind of eyesight to
drive you can see that they're unmarked
and you can see the logo even though
it's hidden
and they have stake plates uh government
plates on them I think they're
identifiable
uh
I don't feel that
I feel that the state police or with
these unmarked vehicles are doing a good
job catching those guys who are doing 80
90 miles an hour on the highways and
thinking that they can get away with it
and I don't like that very much so I'm
not recommending this for future
legislation
anybody else from the committee
representative
I just have one comment that um I
believe this bill as written
specifically had a unfunded mandate that
the department would have to and local
municipalities I believe would have to
take the expense on themselves to
um redo all of the vehicles in their
Fleet which was a huge
um Financial undertaking so for that
matter until we figure out a way to deal
with that I'm I'm good with the
recommendations
anybody else
seeing now the one thing I do remember
that there wasn't I guess the one of the
main reasons for this bill being even
filed was that some some state police
vehicles do have a civilian plate that
they can run as well as their their
police plate
um
I have seen them both being used there's
justifiable uh there's justification for
using the civilian plates in certain
circumstances and even if you see a
Dodge Charger
with civilian plates you might want to
take a look at the hubcaps it's a dead
giveaway so I don't see any need for
future legislation here either
thank you and that being said if there's
nobody else who has to clerk to call the
roll the motion is to not recommend
uh Vice chairman gagne yes
clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes
representative Gorski yes representative
Rambo
yes representative Rich yeah yeah
representative tolerski yes
representative Fox yes representative
yes chairman Walsh
yes
so the recommendation for no
recommendation is 10-0
I'm forgetting to use this thing so I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill 1445
a few minutes please we'll go to 1464.
all right I'll open up the executive
session I would I was uh I missed
misspoke a minute ago I'm going to go to
House Bill 1447 in order prohibiting
state agencies from using face
recognition technology
uh Prime sponsors representative Maguire
this is I don't know if this qualifies
as a perennial bill yet but it's uh it's
been here many times
this is what happens when we go at it
I guess I'll make a motion okay
representative Gorski I'm gonna just
make sure that the language is correct
and act prohibiting state agencies so
I'd say yes I'd like to see this
recommend to move forward
the motion is to recommend future
legislation is there a second
Ed by representative Hill
and he can care to discuss your motion
yes thank you Mr chairman
um when I remember we heard testimony on
this the whole thing about facial
recognition software is that it's
relatively
new there's there are some areas where
there are still areas that it needs to
be improved on
and my view is with something like that
and keeping a database I'm really
concerned uh not only about civil
liberties but I'm also concerned with
the with the technology itself
so therefore I that's why I think we may
want to look forward to maybe future
legislation
representative
for fear of sounding like I'm confused
to the motion
um based on our discussion previously
about this bill in particular is written
um
I feel like there were many unanswered
questions on how this bill is written
would be applied uh
and I believe we were discussing earlier
some of my colleagues and I
that when we had this public hearing we
were discussing the need for guard rails
very more specific
um wording on the use of the technology
what
um
the department is permitted or not
permitted to use
so with that I would have been hopeful
to actually dig deeper into this
um
so it
as long as I'm understanding the
guidelines correctly that we're talking
about this bill as written I would have
to vote no on the motion to recommend
passage on or recommend future
legislation based on this
thank you
fair enough and and referring to the
first bill when I did state that about
the bill specifically uh it's subjective
uh either way this is just a
recommendation
uh
you can look at the bill itself and pick
it apart or not uh this is just do we
think it's even worth looking into and I
think most of us can say it's it's got
some Merit I'll leave it at that it's
entirely up to you which way you'd like
to vote any other discussions from
anybody on the committee
seeing them I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll the motion is to recommend
future legislation on House Bill 1447.
Vice chairman gagging yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
representative Gorski yes
representative Rambo
no
representative rich
Representative tolerski no
representative Fox no representative
vayu
yes
six four so the motion to recommend
future legislation is adopted six four
uh that will close the executive session
on House Bill 1447. and now a few
huge
okay I'm gonna open up the executive
session on interim study bill host Bill
1464 establishing a committee to study
the feasibility and implementation of
furthering electric vehicle adoption in
New Hampshire
uh the prime sponsor I believe is
representative Benton
yep
representative tolersky
I would like to make a motion to
recommend this for future legislation
okay is there a second
okay it's been moved and seconded to
recommend future legislation would you
um
we've had this
spirited debate many times in committee
on the role of this committee with the
electric vehicle industry
um the fact that this was a study
committee
to determine how to
um
further electric vehicle adoption here
in the state
based on the information that right now
those vehicles are going to other states
first I see this as a business issue we
have dealerships here in New Hampshire
that cannot get the vehicles that are in
demand by Granite Staters they're going
over the border to shop elsewhere and I
think it would be in the best interest
of
the state to at least take the time to
sit down and discuss the issue and see
what our role is in it and I feel that
this committee has not yet
um
done that properly so I recommend this
bill for future legislation Mr chairman
thank you representative gagne thank you
Mr chairman
we already have a New Hampshire
Transportation council is doing this
very thing as a matter of fact we're
meeting October 12th
we're having a public hearing on all the
stuff that that this bill would
establish
I don't think we need two committees to
study it the council is very
comprehensive it's dealing uh
Department of Victoria Sheen is involved
in it and in all
all the big players are involved in this
including this small player here and to
me I think to set up another commission
or another committee is just a waste of
time this particular New Hampshire
Transportation council is taking in
everything
into play as far infrastructure Etc and
Etc and Etc so I don't think we need
another commission
I'm going to just add my opinion if you
don't mind I do have to agree we have I
think two books about this thick with
all the established committees we don't
not need anymore especially knowing that
the council exists
um I'm also a firm believer in
the free market determining how these
things move forward not the government
and to keep it even simpler section
three room and one
study of the feasibility of adopting
regulations similar to the California
zero emission vehicle program I would
never vote for anything in the state of
New Hampshire that's got the word
California in it that being said anybody
else
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll the motion is to recommend
future legislation
clerk votes no
representative Hill no
representative Gorski no
representative Rambo yes
representative rich
representative tolerski yes
representative Fox yes representative
yes and chairman Walsh nope it's five to
five no
six four
no it's five five
yeah
it's five to five one two three four
five two three four five there's only
ten of us well that's interesting
so well I mean I would imagine the same
rules apply uh in the tie the the motion
fails
and so I guess we can entertain another
motion but something tells me uh we know
what's going to happen there's
well that's true well usually we try one
of each if it's if if the motion the
second motion to not recommend fails
then it would move forward with none
so let's give it a shot just to keep
keep all the bases covered is there
just to keep it keep all the ducks in a
row are there any other motions to this
hello
I don't have another paper
what we generally do in committee is go
we if the first motion fails we
entertain the positive motion or the
opposite motion if that fails as well
then it'll go on with no recommendation
I've only done we've only done half of
it I move the opposite I I move no
recommendation okay is there a second
yes okay so it's been moved and seconded
to not recommend future legislation I
don't think there's any more discussion
that needs to happen I'll ask the clerk
Vice chairman gagne
the motion is not recommended is that
representative Hill yes representative
representative Rambo
no
representative rich
Representative tulerski no
representative Fox no Representative no
uh chairman Walsh
yes
yep five to five I five okay so this
will move on with no recommendation I'll
confirm that before we leave the
building but I don't see any other other
way to get this accomplished so I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill 1464.
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill 1615 relative to driver
education and the driver training fund
um in summary
Prime sponsors representative Army the
bill director Department of Safety
distribute 250 to approved driver
schools for each pupil who completes the
driver education program in the prior
three months uh is there a motion for
either recommend or not recommended
sure representative Rambo I'd like to
move to not recommend for future
legislation
um I would like to say I think there's a
lot of good intention
I'd like to support the underlying
concept bill but we're not doing that
right now okay
but there's just too many problems I
think as we talked about when we were in
session before so thank you
so it's been moved and seconded to not
recommend future legislation any other
discussion from the committee Rumbo yep
representative thank you I just um
I
admire representative All Me for filing
the the bill
to try to tackle the challenges that we
have with the driver education program
um I think there were obvious problems
that she knew existed right from the
get-go when she presented the bill she
came right out and said we need to study
this further
um I think it's a little unfortunate we
didn't have the chance to dig into this
one
um I think that money from the driver
training fund should go to driver
education schools we have to figure out
how to do that without
um hitting this I think it's the state
police correct yeah in the pocketbook so
we need to figure this out but I agree
that um I think we all agreed with the
prime sponsor that has written it was
not going to do what she wanted it to do
so I'll support the motion
fair enough and I forgot about that but
you're right this not recommend does
have the support of the sponsor so
anybody else
CNN I'll ask the clerk called the roll
the motion is to not recommend future
legislation at this time
Vice chairman gagne yes
Eric votes yes
representative Hill yes
representative Gorski yes
representative rombo yes representative
Rich representative tolerski yes
representative Fox yes representative
yes and chairman Walsh yes
so a recommendation for not recommending
is adopted 10-0 uh I'll close the
executive session on House Bill 1643
next up is no 1615 I apologize next up
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill
1643 modifying the new Resident driver's
um
this bill establishes penalties for
newly established residents failing to
abide by New Hampshire driver's license
requirements
I'm starting to remember this there was
some interest in this bill and I believe
the Secretary of State also
was looking at this favorably or at
least in concept so is there a motion on
the floor
representative tolerski
I make a motion that this is not
recommended for future legislation
second of my representative so the
motion on the floor is to not recommend
future legislation uh any would you care
to speak to your mom sure quickly
um This was
um
a very complicated bill in terms of the
um requirements upon the DMV to
follow up on the residency issue it's
tightly related to
voting issues
the testimony from the DMV was as
written there were many unanswered
questions about how it was going to be
enforced how they would fulfill the
requirements in this bill I believe it
was Ms chute that said it was just
unclear all around how the DMV would
Implement any of this and but the one
thing that really stuck with me was
that this is really imposing motor
vehicle law on those who may not be
driving because it Flags people who um
vote
with an expired license or an
out-of-state license which it is legal
to do in the state of New Hampshire so I
just think that overall there were far
too many
questions
then it actually solving any problem
anybody else
well the one thing I'll say I'll just
chime in a moment as I told you all
before
I put the onus on the prime sponsors of
these bills to address some of the
issues that we had and I remember it was
complicated
um again though this is the only
exception to the other all the nine I
know this Prime sponsor has been working
on addressing some of the issues we're
an executive session now so it's
improper for me to to pull them in front
of the committee but but again we're
just talking about future legislation
and whether it's worthy uh knowing the
work that's been done on behalf of the
Prime sponsor I'm not going to support
the non-recommendation at this time so
if there's nobody else I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll
I'm seeing none and the motion that
we're voting on right now is to not
recommend future legislation
Vice chairman gagging no
chairman votes no
representative Hill no
representative Gorski no
representative Rambo
yes representative rich
representative tolerski yes
representative Fox yes representative
yes
and chairman Walsh
no
I probably six to four to six oh really
yeah
surprise
if they failed four to six so are there
other motions is there a motion for
oh I'll make a motion thank you
representative Gorski the most recommend
future legislation to recommend future
legislation yep is there a second
seconded by representative Hill any
further discussion
seeing none oh Alaska clerk to call the
roll uh once again the motion is
Vice chairman of gagne
yes
work votes yes representative Hill yes
representative Gorski yes
representative Rambo no
representative rich
Representative tolerski no
representative Fox no
Representative no
and chairman Walsh yes
okay so the motion to recommend future
legislation is adopted six four I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill
1643 next up will be 1658 our last house
bill of the year
like
get through your weights and build
all right I'll open up the executive
session on House Bill 1658 relative to
testing in lieu of license renewal fees
Prime sponsor representative Abramson
this bill allows an individual to take a
written test in lieu of paying for
paying a fee to renew their driver's
license
uh is there a motion
to either recommend or not recommend
representative been quiet all day
I I think this one's even got your name
on it
I would move to not recommend thank you
is there a second I will second second
putting you on the spot
um I just think this is kind of not
ready I like the concept but uh I don't
know that it's feasible financially I
think it would be very costly to
administer this for free to to Residents
and uh think financially it doesn't make
I have to agree with you and I don't
know how much there is really to talk
about it I don't actually even quite
understand it anybody else from the
committee
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role the motion is to not recommend
yes all right
clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Gorski yes representative Rambo yes
representative Rich representative
tolerski yes representative Fox yes
representative
yes and chairman Walsh yes
10-0
the motion of not recommend is adopted
10-0 close the executive session on
House Bill 1658
and our last one for the term ladies and
all right I'll open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 308 excuse me
relative to driver's licenses for
certain Visa holders
um Prime sponsors Senator Waters again
this is the Senate bill it had been
amended by the Senate
uh this bill prohibits non-resident
employed
this bill prohibits a non-resident
employed New Hampshire through the
federal h2a temporary agricultural
worker program from operating a motor
vehicle unless they possess license
issued by another U.S jurisdiction or
meet other listed requirements
if you remember we did a lot of work on
this prior to deciding for interim study
some conversations have occurred since
I guess I'll leave it at that is their
emotion whether to recommend future
representative Hill
I would move uh yes to Future
legislation
motion is to recommend future
legislation is there a second
by representative
I knew you'd be surprised
so would you care to speak to motion
no
and I knew you were going to say that
anybody else from the committee
uh again like I said we did genuinely
work on this uh I said it at the time
when we executed the first time that
every time we answered a question we
found uh another one and so
we have been speaking with directive
Motor Vehicles in the meantime
um
to continue the discussion as well as
the the motor vehicles has tried to make
it easier for the for the farmers up
north that were affected and actually
bringing this complaint forward
uh I'll go one step further I've been
trying to confirm but I believe a
different or similar version to this and
to keep it moving uh will probably be
coming out of the Senate this year again
by a different Senator I just haven't
been able to confirm so I have no
opposition to continuing the
conversation to try to solve this I'll
be supporting the motion to
recommend future legislation
if nobody else has anything I'll ask the
clerk to call the rule
yeah Vice chairman gagne yes clerk votes
yes
representative Hill yes representative
Gorski yes representative Rambo yes
representative Rich representative
tolersky yes representative Fox yes
representative yes chairman Walsh yes
all right so the motion to recommend
future legislation is adopted 10-0
uh I'll close the executive session on
Senate Bill 308
that is officially Our Last Action as a
committee for for this term so we
already gave our speeches at our last
meeting so I'm not going to bother doing
it again but thank everybody for coming
and we are out of here there's plenty of
time for lunch thank you so I don't know
who still owes me reports
but we do have to report these
things
I'll get an answer to that too Cameron
where do those reports go so I don't
know but I will find out I mean they're
going to get turned into the clerk but
when did they do anything with them they
don't show up on the docket right
all I did at this point was confirm the
fact that we do need a written report on
them with our recommendation uh I'll
follow up with the clerk they might just
go in the file with the bill I mean it
may not be relative enough to make it on
print in the calendar
so on that form they also list consent
calendar or not
to me it's never a vote so I'm not sure
what this consent calendar is talking
about
wow you're looking you're using the
regular committee report sheets
the actual file sheets of the two
motions can I see one of those please
whatever which one yeah can you read the
majority the one the clerk gave you
uh the exact actual executive session
bill
the only motions are recommended for
future legislation or not there's no
reference to consent for anything so the
sheets that you're giving me the report
on are generic sheets not specific to
so right right so I will confirm with
the clerk where they go I suspect again
they go into the file with this bill
because they all still have a file for
future reference
sure
so when we did two motions
what's that I I didn't have enough
sheets so
um I had to do two motions on one sheet
no I just did it on the front
um I'm just going to show you
one
minority motion not to recommend to not
recommend
um
foreign